man there was a time when Mel Gibson was
America's Sweetheart now he plays
[ __ ] I want to go back I've been Mel
Gibson was mr. good guy back when the
biggest fight you could figure the Sega
Genesis versus Super Nintendo and even
then people didn't really give a [ __ ] we
all game together let's go back
[Music]
daddy's home too so daddy's home - is
this equal to daddy's home which I saw
for the first time pretty recently
long story short discipline cracked me
up at the end of daddy's home one you
see a cameo by John Cena so you're like
alright Mark Wahlberg's gonna have to
ultimately swap roles with Will Ferrell
he's gonna be the underdog now how's
that gonna go doesn't really matter
because they're bringing in the parents
it was like the writers were like we saw
meet the parents and Meet the Fockers
and well how could we not now they're
doing that yeah they bring John Cena in
at the end but it's just one more iron
in an already very clustered fire but I
liked his Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg
they actually do a really good job
together this is not the first time
being on screen together maybe that
praise is a praise for the first movie
what is they're actually quite good when
they're working together also great
casting on the part of their parents
John Lithgow is absolutely who I could
see being the parent of Will Ferrell's
character Mark Wahlberg's character who
it is that'd be yeah Mel Gibson and he's
a total dick in this movie and it does
work conceptually what doesn't work is
the execution the movie is way too
cluttered it's a [ __ ] and quite
frankly it's a bit of a drag the main
schtick of this sequel is not John Luke
cows character it is Mel Gibson's
character you see why Mark Wahlberg was
posturing in the first movie he gets it
from his dad but his dad is truly a dick
in a Christmas movie is a movie that
takes place in the holidays with men of
the holiday cheer as you're watching
this curmudgeon is [ __ ] [ __ ] puff
his chest belittle everybody it's kind
of a drag yes it does have a nice family
message at the end but every movie that
takes place in the holidays has that
it's Christmas movie 101 if you're a
Christmas movie and you don't have that
are you really a Christmas movie and
there's no real comedy with Mel Gibson's
character he just says something douchey
and he laughs at his own joke most of
time Mel Gibson's just walking around
going I have known a hundred of those in
life they're about as entertaining as
you are now that's why I say he was good
casting conceptually and the movie
reuses a lot of the old jokes from the
first one something that lands on the
top of a car-crushing it little Ferrell
getting electrocuted to death there are
a few others let's block Wahlberg's
character in the first movie he was kind
of a dick but you could tell he did have
a heart somewhere in there and even when
he was talking with people like he was
talking to Thomas Haden Church you could
see that he had charm he had charisma
earlier I could see why people gravitate
to this guy Mel Gibson you don't couple
times he walks off with chicks but you
don't hear what he says to them it's
just something that happens in the back
grounds they're like I don't think they
could write any charm for your character
you gotta take the movies word for it
that it works and the movie feels like
it's way too long that's not to say the
movie actually is long in its runtime
but I'm just saying it feels like it's
way too long guys in the end meet the
[ __ ] Gibson was it takes the family
concept that we've seen done in movies
before it takes the Christmas element
that we've seen done in movies and done
better the jokes were bland they were
dry and in some cases were used in the
first movie you feel like a sequel to
daddy's home needed to be vomited out
and now it's been vomited out and you're
just not gonna remember the thing in
t-minus one day ya already forgot I love
to laugh couple of chuckles in this
movie but for the most part no laughs
all right guys so daddy's home - have
you seen it what did you think about it
or it's a sequel that's not as good as
the first movie for you whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]